الليلة نسأل كيف يمكن استعادة الهدوء
إلى أقدس الأماكن في القدس أو
اقتحام الأقصى من قبل القوات الإسرائيلية
يثير إدانة من جميع أنحاء
العالم العربي والإسلامي بما في ذلك الأردن ،
المملكة التي تطالب إسرائيل بسحب
قواتها من الجانب الذي أنا فيه.
السفاري هو وزير الخارجية الأردني
وينضم إلي الآن على الهواء مباشرة وقبل أن نتحدث
عن سيدي القدس تتوقعون مني
أن أبدأ بوضع يتكشف على
حدود إسرائيل مع لبنان عشرات
الصواريخ التي أطلقت على لبنان من
الآن لم يتضح بعد.  من أطلق
تلك الصواريخ لكن من الواضح احتمال حدوث
تصعيد خطير أه في
الوضع الأمني ​​ما هو رد فعلك
سيدي ،
مساء الخير بيكي أه ، من الواضح أن الاثنين
مترابطان أه نحن
للأسف في هذه اللحظة بالضبط
لحظة خطيرة عملنا فيها
لأشهر  اجتناب أه وهي لحظة
يندلع فيها العنف أه ما نراه
يتجلى على الحدود اللبنانية هو
رد فعل تبعي واضح
لما رأيناه يحدث في الأقصى إنه
نتاج اعتداء إسرائيلي غير مبرر
على المصلين السلميين الذين
يؤدون واجبهم الديني أه  نحن
نرى أن ما
رأيناه من قبل يكاد لا يمكنك فعل الشيء نفسه
ونتوقع رد فعل مختلف
قلنا دائمًا أن
احترام حق الفلسطينيين في حرية
العبادة يسمح للناس بالعبادة
بحرية وعدم اقتحام أكسا جيدًا أه
يمنعنا  من الوصول إلى اندلاع
العنف ، للأسف ، فعلت إسرائيل
العكس تمامًا ونحن في هذه
اللحظة الخطيرة جدًا ،
الأردن بالطبع هو خادم
مسجد أليكسا الذي داهمته الشرطة الإسرائيلية
للمرة الثانية في أقل من
24 ساعة
أم المتحدث باسم الشرطة الإسرائيلية
تبرير أه الخطوة كالتالي أه في
أعقاب التحريض المتزايد
جاء مئات الشباب والملثمين
إلى صلاة العشاء في المسجد
ولم يأتوا للصلاة قالوا إنهم
جاءوا بقصد الشغب وإثارة
الفوضى أتوا بالحجارة والألعاب النارية
النباتات الخشبية والقضبان الحديدية
لغرض تحصين عنيف
منعوا العديد من المصلين من مغادرة
المسجد وهذا هو بيان الشرطة الإسرائيلية
أنا السفاري ردك
على ذلك
أه بيكي أعتقد أن الصور والصور
التي يحملونها كانت  الدنيا كلها
أه كذب هذه الرواية أه
المصلين كانوا أه يؤدون
واجباتهم الدينية أه بسلام أه
المئات من رجال الشرطة الإسرائيلية اقتحموا
الأقصى وقاموا بتخريب
المكان وغادروا ثم رد الناس
وهذه ليست المرة الأولى التي
يكون فيها هذا  لقد حدث ذلك من قبل وقد حدث ذلك
مرة أخرى في الأشهر التي سبقت شهر
رمضان لأنه كما تعلمون
بالتعاون مع الولايات المتحدة مع
شركاء إقليميين آخرين من مصر الإمارات ،
كل شخص يحاول العمل
لتجنب هذه اللحظة بالضبط وقد
جعلناها رائعة للغاية.  من الواضح أننا إذا أردنا أن
نمر خلال شهر رمضان بسلام ،
يجب احترام حق المصلين
ولم نر ذلك ، لقد رأينا
إسرائيل تفرض حظرًا على كل
فلسطيني دون سن الأربعين من
الذهاب لأداء الواجب الديني  لقد
رأينا عرضًا ساحقًا
للقوة ، لذا إذا تركته إسرائيل
للعمل الأردني لإدارة
المكان لكان بإمكاننا التعامل
مع أي حادث فردي ، لكن
هناك القليل جدًا مما يمكن أن يؤديه العمل 60
70 مرشدًا  عندما اقتحمت الشرطة المكان مرة أخرى
ودفعتهم بعيدًا وأثارت
المواجهة مع الشباب
المحبطين الغاضبين بالفعل
نعم تلك الكلاب أم
أم أن هؤلاء الحراس الذين لديهم
وزير المكان المقدس تحت
حراسة السفينة الأردنية ووفقًا
لبيان الشرطة الإسرائيلية حاولوا
منع  نقلا عن تحصين عنيف
من الفلسطينيين داخل المسجد أن
هذا صحيح
أه أولا وقبل كل شيء بيكي مرة أخرى الصور
والفيديوهات التي رأيناها أثبتت أنه
لا يوجد تحصين رقم اثنين ما
قام به العمل لأي
سبب تنظيمي لوجستي نصح الناس
أه أه يؤخرونهم  أداء
الواجبات الدينية في الليل لا يمكن لأحد أن
ينزع من المصلين
حق العبادة وهو حق مقدس وبالتأكيد
ليس عمل لا لم أكن أعرفه ولا
يمكن لأي شخص آخر أن يأمر الناس بعدم
الذهاب إلى المسجد والصلاة  لذلك هذا
مرة أخرى هو تحريف للحقيقة
في النهاية بيكي ، أعتقد أن
السؤال البسيط هو أن أكسا هي مكان
عبادة إسلامي معترف به من قبل
العالم بأسره والذي يعترف به
قرار اليونسكو ما هي الأعمال التجارية التي تقوم إسرائيل
بدخولها إلى المسجد
و  منع الناس من
العبادة هذا هو السؤال الأساسي
والذي أعتقد أنه يتحدث إلى أه
حقيقة أوسع بيكي عندما تضع
شخصًا أدانته إسرائيل
نفسها بتهمة التحريض العنصري
وكان عضوًا في منظمة
صنفتها الولايات المتحدة نفسها على أنها
منظمة إرهابية ، لقد وضعت هذا
الشخص مسؤولاً عن قوة الشرطة وأعتقد
أنني لست بحاجة إلى رؤيتهم جميعًا
في هذا الصدد ،
نعم أنت تتحدث عن
الوزارة الإسرائيلية بالطبع تفعل
الإجراءات الإسرائيلية في ألاسكا
ووجود الشرطة في الموقع المقدس
تنتهك اتفاقية الوضع الراهن مع
الأردن ، نعم أو لا على
الإطلاق ، تفعل
أجنبيًا